-I'm assuming you get asked
something that we get asked
all the time, which is, "Does
Trump make your job easier?"
-Mm-hmm, yeah, which is --
It's very hard
for people to understand
just how viscerally upsetting
that question is.
-Yeah.
-Because it doesn't.
It makes it harder.
My wife, in the past,
has had to pull me away
from entirely well-meaning
people in the street, saying,
"Well, I guess it just
writes itself, doesn't it?"
and I'll say,
"I'll tell you whether
it [bleep] writes itself or --
No, I'm talking to the lady!
She wants to know
how easy it is.
I'll [bleep] tell her
how easy it is."
[ Laughter ]
No, it's -- it's harder.
It's harder.
Because, um, you know,
it's easy to do bad comedy,
because you just
need to repeat what he says,
and that's not a joke.
That's repetition.
-Yeah.
-Whereas comedy,
especially if you want
to try and do something
that's not just happening
online all the time,
is an effort.
I'm not telling you something
you don't already feel
with every fiber
of your exhausted being.
-Yeah.
You do a lot of deep dives
on stories that are
a little uncovered,
but you do spend a few minutes,
I feel, like,
covering the Trump news
at the top of your show,
usually.
And it seems like
you pick up --
'Cause you go on Sunday,
you kind of pick up
the end-of-the-week news.
-Yeah. So we literally started
thinking, at one point --
What time do you tape?
Because it's probably
about 5:30, right?
-We tape at 6:30, yeah, but
we're done at 5:30, yeah.
-Exactly.
So, about 5:30 on a Thursday,
at that point, you have dealt
with the fire-hosable [bleep]
to the extent that you can,
at which point the depressing
relay baton is put over to us.
So, from Thursday
at 5:30 onwards,
it's our turn to open our mouth
and take that fire hose in.
[ Laughter ]
Listen
to that revolted response.
"Was that analogy necessary?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Well, I want to speak about
another analogy of sorts.
This was a couple years ago.
You said that America was
entering their Fat Elvis stage.
-No, that was more
than a couple of --
That was a long time ago.
-That was really --
It was a long time ago.
-I think that was pre-Obama.
-Wow.
-The argument then
was saying that, yeah, exactly,
you were kind of Elvis
in his Vegas years back then.
Still objectively great...
-Yeah.
-...but you could sense
the sadness coming.
[ Laughter ]
-And that has really
kind of followed through.
-Well, it has followed through.
'Cause at that point,
I thought that was as silly
as it could get, and that
now seems a quaint idea,
because I don't know what period
of Elvis you're in right now,
but I think he's about to reach
for the flusher.
[ Laughter ]
-Or we've now gone past --
This is --
In our analogy, Elvis lived.
-I think that's right.
-Yeah.
-That is the really positive way
to think about it
is that Elvis faked his death,
and he's back,
and he's living a weird,
weird life.
-Yeah.
-That's the Elvis you are now.
-It's weirder
than Vegas Elvis, yeah.
-So that is the perfect --
that is the perfect
distillation, I think,
of optimism and negativity.
Negativity is,
"Elvis is dead now.
He died,
and he's dead forever."
Optimism is,
"Elvis never died,
and he's about
to make a comeback album
louder than ever before."
[ Laughter ]
-And it'll be, like,
"Is it the classics?"
It's like, "No, it's crazy
new stuff that you..."
-That's right.
He's into drum --
-That's the balance is like,
"He's alive."
That's the good news.
The bad news is,
it's crazier than ever.
-He's like Sting.
He's really into lute music now.
[ Laughter ]
-He's doing a live lute concert.
-That's right.
And he's doing drum and bass.
He really likes drum and bass.
-Oh, good.
That's what Elvis needed.
I do want to ask --
I forgot to ask this earlier,
because Beyoncé is also
in the "Lion King" film.
-Whoo!
-Yes. That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's --
That is the appropriate response
to the word "Beyoncé."
-Yeah.
-And that's real-life royalty,
Beyoncé.
-Oh, gotcha.
So, have you met her?
-I would drop
to my [bleep] knees.
-Oh, you would.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't.
Please.
Don't look at me, Queen.
Don't look at me, Queen!
-It is really --
She's a very hard person --
-Have you met her?
-Like, only in those very brief
"SNL" sort of, like,
passing moments.
-That counts.
-It counts,
but it renders you wordless.
-Did she say hello to you?
-Yes.
-You met her!
-Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I don't --
I don't care that you're sick.
-All this stuff.
These were here.
-Two years ago, at the Emmys,
I was supposed
to be sitting behind her,
and she didn't turn up.
And my only plan
for the whole Emmys
was to watch
the back of her head
and witness her interacting with
her immediate surroundings.
-Yeah. With all due respect to
whoever is hosting the Emmys,
nothing -- no one
has ever done it better
than the back of Beyoncé's head.
-That's right.
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah, she's in
the "Lion King," as well,
and I am absolutely sure
that I will not
be allowed to meet her,
especially after this interview.
-No.
-This feels like something
her security team
should be made aware of
in some way.
"He seems a little highly strung
when her name comes up."
-Your show's on a holiday break,
but Catheter Cowboy
is gonna be in action.
For those who don't know,
you want to give a quick
description of Catheter Cowboy?
-Yeah, it's quite hard
to explain.
But, basically, there is
a Catheter Cowboy on Fox News,
and Fox News is obviously where
our current president
gets lots of information,
which is both fact and sad.
And so to try
and sneak information to him,
we've been taking out ads
on Fox News
with our own Catheter Cowboy,
trying to explain to him things
like what the Nuclear Triad is.
-Yeah.
-And so he will be --
While we're away,
he will be appearing
sporadically on Fox News,
trying to get information
into his unyielding head.
-And so these are ads that
you've shot and time bought.
-That's right.
They will be --
They will be getting rolled out
until they are stopped.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it's always
very difficult times
when you guys are on a break.
I hope you can rest,
although I know you guys
rarely do.
But it shows up
in the work you do,
and I'm just so happy
to have you here.